the big day has arrived queen elizabeth
finally meets her namesake baby little
bit face to face a source confirms to
e.t prince harry and meghan markle
introduced the queen to their 11 month
old daughter lillabet diana after
thursday's trooping the color event
draped in white dior for her first
formal public appearance in the uk since
mexic she held hands with harry for much
of the time there were smiles for the
cameras cheers and a few boos from the
crowd less than 15 months after their
bombshell oprah interview
of course megan gave birth to their
little girl who was also named after
harry's late mom princess diana back in
june 2021 in california amid the
pandemic with the sussex family on the
west coast and the queen in england they
didn't have a chance to meet sooner but
we have a feeling that long wait made it
even more special she hasn't seen archie
for nearly two years now and she hasn't
seen harry for well over a year so she
would have been i'm sure delighted to
have got to see him and megan and the
queen's reunion with archie also
happened marking the first time she's
seen lillabet's big brother since megan
and harry stepped away from their royal
duties and moved to the states i can
imagine that she would be very pleased
to have seen harry i think the queen
particularly given that she's not 100 at
the moment would have just wanted this
to be a warm encounter of course the
reason for the sussex family's trip
across the pond to celebrate the queen's
platinum jubilee honoring 70 years of
service on the throne but the 96 year
old monarch has already run into some
conflicts for events in her honor e.t
has learned the queen will not attend
the platinum party nor the epson derby
on saturday but is expected to watch it
at windsor castle the queen won't be
going to tomorrow's horse races at epsom
and she won't be at the party at the
palace here but there is a hope that she
will get to meet her namesake lily bett
on her first birthday clearly family
always comes first
[Music]
you